parents
uh try to solve a chess puzzle from a
local newspaper and uh
and i just discovered the the mystery of
this
little wooden chessboard you know
64 squares 32 pieces nobody told me how
to move the pieces i learned by just
watching them you know so and
at one point you know i revealed that i
knew some of the secrets it was match
made in heaven
when i play chess it's
it was every
how are you looking at the game
you play you have to
invest you know all you have yeah so
whether you may call it a war it's a
side it may call psychological warfare
i realized that it's not just about
chess and that's another important
lesson for my mother
so yes chess is about winning and losing
but
it's also about making the difference
[Music]
one thing i like
i like to talk to the greatest of all
time in their industries whatever that
may be i like to speak to people that
are the greatest in their industry okay
in their industry
and the reason why we reached out to him
uh and he told me last night when we
were having dinner i don't know if you
caught that tim when he said at the
dinner last night he said the last time
i did a live event was january of 2020.
we're talking a year and nine months ago
year and 10 months was the last time he
did an event to make it on this trip he
had to go all over the place i'm sure
he's going to tell us the story so i'm
excited to have him here but the book
your next five moves talks about knowing
how to have your next five 10 15 moves
can you imagine
how many guys have been number one in
sales for one month how many guys have
been number one is how many guys have
been number one in sales for three
months straight in a big company in a
company with a thousand people to
compete with you were number one three
months straight how many guys have been
number one for six months straight how
many guys have been number one for 12
months straight how many guys have been
number one for two years straight three
years straight four years straight five
years straight six years straight seven
years straight you want to continue he
was number one every month from seven
billion people around the world that
played chess for
250 consecutive
months
in chess
that's absolute insanity
there is no other sport or athlete can
even say something like that
250 consecutive months they call them
the goat of the game of chess a game
many play
a few master and a few become a teacher
that teaches other masters give it up to
the one and only gary kasparov
[Music]
[Applause]
you're fine
what what it's a good way to start your
weekend why do i get a feeling you're
super competitive
is that is that a misread on me or is it
because
even when you came to dinner last night
and you sat at dinner i'm like your
level of intensity was felt when you sat
at the table i i never thought that it
was doing anything unless you you know
you invest all for yourself so i i also
know the limits of my ignorance so if
i'm not you know up to the task so if i
know that this topic is just you know
outside of the sphere of my competence
so i stay away but if i'm in
it's full monty that's full monty if
you're in okay so so for some that don't
know your story i mean listen it's a
very
uh uh uh very very interesting story
that you got and obviously how you came
up competing we'll talk about that going
up against the ibm machine we'll talk
about that being number one for 200 and
some sites say 251 some say 255. i want
to say the right number should waste our
time debating that what is the number
does it 250 look i don't know it was too
long to count
imagine
you're so good for so long you're like
it doesn't matter anymore okay so then
then you had issues with putin maybe
we'll talk about that you you have
issues with dictators that's good i like
that i believe okay good we can talk
about that and i grew up in the soviet
union so when i in 1991 30 years ago yes
i thought that okay that was the end of
the nightmare i was wrong
okay good so we want to talk about that
is because this group just so you know
it's very comfortable talking politics
so don't worry about it they're business
people again just to give them optics
raise your choice you're asking for
trouble no you we talked about that i
told you you said don't ask me questions
you don't want to ask
i'm not a politician i'm not in front
office i don't waffle i don't duck good
you ask the question you get a straight
answer we are aware of that we like that
listen we we like that
the the good thing about the channel
valuetainment and the people we've
interviewed i've interviewed very very
random people so i'm accustomed to
people like you it's actually fantastic
okay so if somebody doesn't know your
story
go all the way back
who was gary how did he come up how did
he start winning becoming the
you know chess player that he is today
so do we start from the very beginning
at one very beginning very very
beginning so born in uh april 13 1963
in the deep south right next to the
george georgia
so actually it was a republic of
azerbaijan and soviet union right next
to the republic of georgia
so um
and uh um
i cannot tell you the moment when i
actually learn how to play chess
because unfortunately nobody was there
to tweet about it
yeah
it was um
winter
evening 68 69 my parents
try to solve a chess puzzle from a local
newspaper and uh
and i just discovered the the mystery of
this
little wooden chessboard you know you
know 64 squares 32 pieces nobody told me
how to move the pieces i learned by just
watching them you know so and and at one
point you know i revealed that i knew
some of the secrets
and um it was match made in heaven so
very quickly you know so they just
recognized that instead of sending me to
a music school because all my parents
from my father's sides
are all these uh relatives were
musicians um that's the jewish side so
um uh and um and he said no no it's just
you know that's the
that's that's not for gary so he's a
different kind of mind so
so and i was sent to a chess club at age
seven
it's sadly it was his last decision he
uh he died from leukemia it's when i was
seven
and for the next 50 years so i was
under the divine shield of my mother
who sadly passed last christmas you know
from carved and
and she spent her entire life you know
working for me for your only son and
and um that was the beginning that was
the beginning and uh very quickly i
realized that uh chess would be my life
um but also i realized that it's not
just about chess and that's another
important lesson from my mother
so yes chess is about winning and losing
of course it's about winning um
but
it's also about making the difference
and that's
that's that was a fundamental you know
like message to me that i carried
throughout
my entire life and that's why i could
rebuild my life after i left
professional chess in 2005 because it's
it's about making a difference and
that's answer to your first you know
question it's about intensity if i'm in
you know i have to try to make the
difference maybe not as much as i did in
the world of chess but anywhere so i
believe that we can make a contribution
so and that's the like motto of my life
so it's the i even had it on the top of
my of my bed she put it when i was 11 or
12. if not you who else
i mean just don't complain about others
don't complain about weather conditions
this is about you powerful so this is
you can do whatever you want as long as
you're in so when you devote yourself to
again whatever task you've selected gary
how much of the drive was there any you
said your father passed away when you
were seven years old how much drive came
from there to want to make him proud was
there any drive where you're like i'm
gonna go out there and do something big
to leave a legacy for the last name was
there anything there look up
absolutely so it's uh and again this is
the fact that my mother never remarried
and she just you know she she made this
big sacrifice you know um i i knew that
i had to i had to be up to the challenge
so look
we still need a little bit of luck you
know with with our professional career
even if you have a talent and you're a
hard worker and by the way it's i always
you know
argue with people who say oh
he or she you know has a great talent
uh uh or
otherwise actually it's not so talented
but has you know is a hard worker i
believe the hard work is also talent
so again that's another interesting
mother oh so you believe a person who
works hard that is a form of a talent
it's of course a talent you know this is
exactly
look talent is something that is
possessed by few or not everybody and we
know that not everybody's a hard worker
so which means working hard as a talent
and when you combine it with your
natural talent
for chess for uh whatever so just
whatever field you you selected so
that's that's an explosive combination
and i knew that working hard was was
crucial i grew up in you know in the
family family was a very modest means
um
in the soviet union and very quickly i
recognized that you know that's the
the uh the stories that we received from
tv from newspapers um that were very
different from you know from what you
could see around so as i that was the
beginning of my political education how
old were you when you figured that out
look at this quite early i had my um my
uncle my the younger brother of my
father uh who
was part of this you know in you know
circle circles of intelligence so and
and this you know he supplied me with
some books that were not available in in
the public libraries and also because of
my chess successes i could travel
and traveling in in the soviet union and
traveling abroad was was rare so at age
13 as the
as the youngest soviet
junior champion under 18.
so i was
representing my country in france
so
i think that in our neighborhood
in baku in the city of baku which was
the fourth largest city in the soviet
union i don't think we had anyone who
traveled you know in the capitalist
country so i i became a star by the very
fact that you know i could travel there
came back and again i could see things
i could compare them with official
propaganda and um it would it didn't
take long for me to actually recognize
what was right and what was wrong
yeah my mother my family is from baku by
the way
uh baku yeah my mother's side and i
almost married a girl from baku but my
family's from baku
so i know we have a lot in common huh
yeah we do from but but you know they're
armenian but but let's see what words
actually that's that's that's my that's
my second that's my mother's side
armenia
bistra i got a few words
i got a few more but i'm gonna keep it
safe here so let's go back so if if i
knew you and we were in school together
at what point did everybody in russia
know who gary was because it starts off
first locally they know who you are you
win a competition then they know you you
know maybe region and then the entire
country knows here's who gary is he's a
phenom what was that process like yeah
again look it's it's i i um
i climbed you know just at this you know
the chess
stairs rapidly so by age nine i was the
first category player uh by age ten i
was a candidate's master
but as i mentioned at age 12 i won the
junior national championship under 18 12
18. so that's the and by the way next
year i repeated my success just one
twice in a row
so um and soviet unit at the time was
the by far the strongest chess country
in the world so i proved you know to be
a great talent you know chess prodigy uh
and um and i'd say everybody knew my
name already but um again even if your
name is well known it's still a long way
to go to the very top and uh
a part of you know
obvious chess challenges i had other
challenges i was half armenian half
jewish in the soviet union you're half
an inch
of course i have armenian
do you speak the language or no no i
don't i grew up in baku but this is
didn't you have you read my wikipedia of
course i have i'm trying to
wise i'm trying
my my look you know i grew up in baku
and the group in the russians but
armenia i didn't know you were armenian
i'm telling you right now i'm in front
of my god
my ancestors come from nagorno-karabakh
this is that state that's the whole
compose from my gran my grandmother and
grandfather but unfortunately i never
made it there so let's say
and um it's it's it was quite tragic
that my mother died you know just seeing
her ancestor land being taken away
so by azeri troops so uh and we had to
escape in 1990 because it was just you
know it was you may call epic cleansing
or genocide so we had to escape from
baku in 1990. though i was a big
a big uh hero but um the fact that i had
50 of armenian blood you know made me
unwelcome in my in the city of my birth
um
so um that's and i had to face anatoly
corporal
a darling of the system a russian
champion you know embraced and kissed by
brezhnev so that was extra challenge
trust me so and um
and i i recognize that it's not just
about moving the pieces
it's also you know just taking a stand
and um so i
it's it's like it was
parallel education playing chess getting
better getting you know climbing you
know eventually challenging karpov in
1984 so at age 21 but also recognizing
the shortcomings of the system and
somehow feeling that one day i would
take a stand to challenge it
nowadays if somebody wants to get better
at the chess i can play it on an ipad i
can play on
what was your strategy for getting
better back in the days what did you
read what did you have access to look
you know it's
um
i just got you know from moscow so my
cousin brought to me archives that my
mother kept
and those my
notebooks from the 70s 73 74 75 you know
handwritten notes and i showed it to my
kids
my daughter's turning 15. i mean she
couldn't believe that you know we had to
collect the data so this is now
it's all here we had to write the games
i even you know had a special set it's
by my coach
he gave me great present it's from east
germany i i could push i could put a
stamp with a diagram and then put chess
pieces on it so it's this is
again it was time consuming but it was a
great contribution to to my work ethics
yeah because i had to do and and it's
it's again
my kids you know just that couldn't
believe it this is this all this you
know notebooks
many you know many pounds of of of the
paper it's just this written so i think
it's just it's the
it's
life is always about trade-offs and of
course you know we had to spend so much
time but we could value information
treasury information you know i started
kasparov chess foundation in this
country 20 years ago and from 2005 we
have regular sessions with talented kids
when i said talented kids it's a top
level so and i can proudly say that u.s
juniors now does the best in the world
so that's we've made a contribution to
this success and uh more and more i
could see that you know the way they
play is so much influenced by machines
and it's it's good that they can collect
all the data today the kid at age 12
knows more than bobby fischer learned in
his entire life again simply because he
or she could have swiped the finger and
just find all the data
but again how you deal with this data i
mean it's just it's the this how can you
process it can you just you know
merge it with your intuition with your
human qualities because when we analyze
the games i i look at them and say okay
here's a move i said ah it's not a good
move so why it's not a good move
because machine said so
so i can also look at the screen can you
tell me why and many of them stared at
me
i'm being confused what do you mean why
because machine said so
so this is sometimes you know they lose
the this the ability the very human
ability to to look deep down and
understand you know what it's all about
so it's you know it's just it's the many
ways of of of
describing the difference between humans
and machines making making decisions and
i always like to bring a quote from one
of the founding fathers of of ai joseph
weizenbaum who created eliza that's a
siri prototype in 1964 1965 in his book
in 1976 he talked about
difference between deciding and choosing
it's very subtle but he explained it
that you know this
deciding is for machines because it's
computational
choosing is very human because at the
end of the day when you go way down with
machine
go to the very bottom yeah
i did it because i was told so
with human you go deep down
i did it because i wanted
so it's very important to recognize that
you know no matter you know how much ai
is being introduced in our lives we will
remain indispensable that's what i
learned you know from the game of chess
so this is always an element of
human unique human qualities that cannot
be replaced by by machines i don't want
to sound callous yes every technology
you know brings problems and and you
know destroys industries but it also
creates opportunities
and it's very important for us to
understand even if we belong to the last
few decimal places
so what it's still very important for us
to actually find a way to channel this
immense power of
this brute force very question for you a
question for you what you're saying
because what you're saying is uh we
talked about this last few days and it's
a topic of discussion nowadays that the
thought about
computers eventually one day taking over
and doing the work of mankind absolutely
okay tell us unless you're brainwashed
by hollywood and the army of doomsayers
it's
yeah look you know it's very simple you
know this is the it's the you should
treat
computers ai whatever it is we can
discuss the the the uh the names it's
it's another human creation
it's not a magic wand
but it's not a terminator
it's not a harbinger of utopia or
dystopia it is a tool
you don't expect this to bring you to
heaven but it's not going to open the
gates of hell
and yeah it's easy to sell fear that's
why you have army of doomsayers telling
you oh wow
we're all going to die why machines made
us stronger
machines made us faster
intelligent machines will make us
smarter
if we know how to use it
so there's so many new opportunities
just being open every day and by the way
we we're just now getting out of the
pandemic crisis
and it's in many of the debates we had
in the past you know oh it's
would you like to have driverless cars
or robots in the hospitals how many
lives could be saved if we had you know
these machines you know helping us
during this crisis and also this is
something that people just don't
recognize when they talk about computers
when we go back to chairs
oh machines you know just you know if if
they don't reach 100 perfection they're
no good
nonsense
there's no perfection in you in the
universe
all you should expect from computers to
do better
to make fewer mistakes
you mentioned my match with ibm computer
in 1997. yeah
actually i won the first one in 1996
just for the sake of historical record
[Applause]
and you know faced other computers as
well but you know people say oh the 1997
match you know gary against the blue
that was the dawn of artificial
intelligence
yes
but i can tell you that the blue was as
intelligent as your alarm clock
now a very expensive one about 10
million dollar piece
but still it was not intelligent at all
it didn't have to be intelligent
all it had to do is to make fewer
mistakes
it played decent chess
but it made fewer mistakes by the way if
you have a chess app on your mobile
it's as good or even better than the
blue
today
so and the gap between
best chess player in the world today
magnus carlson and
a chess engine that you can download on
your laptop
it's about the same as between usain
bolt and ferrari
so what
it's the it's this is again recognizing
that game of chess
game of goal
uh game of shocking japanese chess
video games like starcraft or dota
texas holdem poker
those are all what i would call closed
systems
and the moment we we humans design the
framework machines will do a better job
simply because they make fewer mistakes
and that's you know that's the same goes
with the drivers cars
the moment something goes wrong with
driver's car you have a front page of a
newspaper
now what about 40 000 people being
killed you know on the roads of of this
country every year by human mistakes
so again the moment we understand that
you know we cannot push machines to
perfection and we could you know get you
know again this is like improving our
bottom line that's what we need
sami now just goes with ai and just in
business you know so many executives and
i speak a lot of course as as patrick
mentioned you know my last event was in
in january 2020 in france so but but
since that i had so many uh online
events
and i could even even on the screen i
could feel this anxiety fear you know so
how can we bring it in what about
explainability
so what are you there you know just to
explain you know how much it works or
you want to improve your bottom line
so it's it's it's in it we should not
expect what machines cannot do but we
should also be very open understanding
what it can bring to us and how we can
actually merge itself how we can bring
together us and machines that's what i
knew in 1997 that's what i you know why
i introduced a so-called advanced chess
humans plus machines it's about finding
how humans and machines collaborate
that's the way to look into the future
fantastic with a question for you though
because you did say when you went
against deep blue it just makes fewer
mistakes than a human does right so if
you
were to get 50 phenoms
math phenoms they're great at math but
they've never played the game of chess
you get them you coach them for a year
a computer gets these 50 phenoms and we
do a project together the computer
teaches them
chess for 12 months okay so you got
computers ai you got gary kasparov with
writing on a sheet of paper 12 months
later these kids play against each other
who's going to be better at the game of
chess one why it will be one-sided which
side outside tell me why easily why
because it's about teaching because it's
about it's about you know uh
transferring data this is you know this
is that's what i said you know you have
closed systems
but there's not a shred of evidence that
machines can transfer data from one
closed system to another closed system
even if you have you know the computer
you know dominating in starcraft pick up
a video game
the moment you shift it from one map to
another you have to start from the
scratch that's again it's fantastic but
but again it's this is still a very
human human role to actually to to um
transfer the data
now this is i always you know i like you
know the quote that goes not from
science but from art from pablo picasso
who said computers are useless because
they can only give you answers
think about it
answers only
because it's it's as a great artist he
knew that you know to be creative you
know you have to ask questions questions
are a beginning
and that's where we belong
we have to ask questions oh machines
also can ask questions
yes but they do not know what questions
are relevant
it's very important that you understand
what matters most
and that's why and i remain optimistic
also the machines getting more
sophisticated good good for me i'm 58 i
will never be as savvy as my kids you
know just you know
working with computers but this is a
moment where i believe my expertise my
wisdom my experience could actually be
an important factor to start you know um
very successful collaboration with with
these machines that will not require you
know a lot of technical uh knowledge let
me ask you a direct pointed question and
and i'm curious on how you react to this
are you saying that because you firmly
believe that are you saying that because
you have to believe that because
that's your signature meaning like if a
computer does better than gary kasparov
what's what's gary's you know so so are
you kind of defending your own uh
philosophy because
i'll give you an idea like you know how
people say stuff like you know uh time
magazine wrote an article talking about
the fact that millennials are lazier
generation than the current generation
right in rice's article you know
they don't work as hard they're all what
they want to do is they want to be on
instagram they want to do this and our
generation didn't do that and at the end
it says
if you say the next generation is lazy
it's just a sign that you're getting old
because the generation prior used to
also say that you were lazy so do you
think there's a part of us as we're
coming up
that we almost don't want to give in to
say ai is taking over it's going to do
the job better than us
um
do i look like someone who has any
doubts about what i'm saying
well that's the problem though that's
what i'm saying
the reason why i'm pushing your back on
this is to say do we sometimes have
blind spots because we're so
confident of what worked 20 years ago
maybe not today i was the first
knowledge worker on this planet who had
his job threatened by a machine
but i you know
and i again all i did after the 99 1997
match you know
oh
first i wanted to play the re-rematch
the third match and ibm made a good
business decision they knew that the
blue was good but you know the third
match probably would you know would
give me a good chance of winning so and
since they know they had one of the
highest uh
performance for two weeks because the
ibm shares jumped 22
you know over the two weeks you know
since we when we played the match
and many of my friends said that my
biggest mistake was not to lose the
match but not to us the options
uh and uh um
um and uh i wanted to play the real
rematch and they said they turned me
down and i just i i was really upset you
know so i was looking forward just you
know for for just you know to prove that
you know i was still the best
and um and then the blue disappeared so
i just actually recently rediscovered
that many of them probably also saw it
it's it's it's it's doing sushi in jfk
airport terminal 5.
it's a great it's a great bar deep blue
so i love sushi never ate there
so but um
uh but speaking about this is it's it's
it's the machine says ah you know i i
wanted you know to
learn you know what's next and as i said
you know the next is working together
you cannot beat them join them
again this is this is it's it's i took
time you know for me to analyze you know
this is the our performance versus their
performance but i found out that
machines will always have shortcomings
and the future of any successful
business is to finding the way how to
make contribution unique human
contribution to the very specific
machine to create a combination that
will be most effective for this task
sounds easy
but it's tough and those who can master
the process will be on top
of the food chain
so um um i you know i have nothing to
gain about 58 so that's already i'm you
know i'm i belong to the generation that
that is threatened by the computers but
again i i i'm an optimist because i
believe you know machines will also help
us to realize our wildest dreams
by the way we dream machines cannot
dream even in sleeping mode
so it's important that you know we we
see this as opportunity
i'm an optimist incorrigible optimist by
nature
despite the fact i was born in the
soviet union and had to live from
putin's russia to live in exile but i
still believe you know in in the future
of humanity and i see so many things
that happening at the same time it's
probably it's kind of an irony that
during the pandemics we saw the another
breakthrough in the space
with nasa with elon musk so this is
important we are pushing forward by the
way it's not we or as all humanity
people who board raised and work in the
free world
so that's why i believe freedom is so
important because that's the only
guarantee that the progress will never
get stalled
you're speaking to an audience that's on
the side with you by the way i'm just
pushing back just curious to know what
you thought about that going back to
when you talked about when you faced
anatoly karpov i think you were what 21
22 years ago
prior to him who was the most
intimidating opponent you faced was
there anybody you faced where you were
you didn't know whether you were going
to beat them or not
no
you don't even remember it
no it's about being it's not remembering
it's this you know carpool was of course
my nemesis you know this because we
played five world championship matches
we spent hundreds of hours you know
uh in front of each other at the
chessboard but again just going back to
what my mother told me it's it's about
you
so whatever happened in the game of
chess it was always you know
my own contribution
i did well i won i did poorly i lost but
there's no one to blame
so it's the
yeah i had tough opponents but i always
knew that if i could improve
i would win
when you face them and you won you
became the champion what was that like
when you became the champion the first
time and
you were at the top of the world the
first time what was i feeling like look
i am
it's probably quite ironic that my first
memory of the moment being the world
champion it's i won my
last game against karpov game 24 1985 on
november 9th
so and next day there was a ceremony
award ceremony so and um uh and even in
my book even i just you know i i i made
it like an introduction because with all
these you know hugs and kisses you know
and gary
you know that so that's it uh i was
standing on the stage you know um
you know just look at the picture has
this big hair
uh
flowers laurel
and uh
all i remember it's uh it's then i was
approached by
a widow of one of the former world
champions arona petrossian another
armenian so tigran pedrozian was one of
my mentors
and she looked at me
it was a glimpse of sadness and she said
young man
i'm sorry for you what
sorry for me i'm 22 i'm the best on this
planet the sky is the limit and she
repeated i'm sorry for you because the
happiest day of your life has just
passed
can you imagine to hear it at age 22
i i i have to admit i i didn't pay much
attention to that okay things happen but
then i you know it was it it got it so
somehow it got stuck and and i thought
oh what was it a curse or a blessing
because it could be a curse but also it
gave me reasons to prove her wrong
so just you know to do other things you
know just to make sure that you know i
could you know
push the horizon not only the game of
chess and i stayed on top for a long
time but it's just do other things and
uh
and um i that's what that's what i
remember and i think it was a great
start
because it just it's it's it's made me
recognize that you know it's the you
know you can you cannot seize the
process of exploration
and learning and um
again that's that's it's
i think we all
hear a lot of advices
from
you know from right left and the center
but it's for us to pay attention it's
again to understand what matters most
i recognize that this warning
was sort of
like a greatest push into my future
from 84 to 05
you're number one
yeah
how the hell do you do that
no no you act like it's normal because
you're you like you've been you your
entire life but we we are you know we're
every other sport no one's been number
one for 21 years how do you do that look
um
is it the game different is it your
discipline is it your wanting to prove
that lady wrong that said this is going
to be the biggest point highest point
for you is it your father's drive is it
your mom supporting you what was it
all together
you just keep keep counting
because keep counting because you need
it's this is a combination it's not just
one factor it's all about it's it's all
together plus many more but on top of
that is just you know it's the it's the
something i learned is and that's the
that's again was very important lesson
it
goes beyond chess it's for business for
life for politics it's uh
if we lose the game
whether it's in chess whether it's
another sport whether in in business
deal or political campaign we know we
did something wrong and we have to go
back and we have to study
where we made the mistake
now if we want
naturally it's because we're great and
would like to celebrate
now i can tell you someone who stayed on
top for so long perfect game doesn't
exist
if you won
for a simple reason because your
opponent made the last mistake
and it's most likely you also made
mistakes or
inaccuracies
they always know things to improve
and
i think one of the key elements of my
success was that i was relentless with
myself so i was brutally honest
so i looked at my games and i won many
more than i lost of course
and i knew that you know in order to win
next day i have to look at what i did
find my mistakes and come back you know
being again at the cutting edge
so what i figured out that if you are
challenging your own excellence you will
never run short of opponents
so that's that was simple so i i knew
that it's all about improving my game
even staying on top
because the moment you want to rest on
your rails
you are in trouble as it put in my book
success
is very often the greatest enemy of
future success
because it can blind us of course
we think we did it because because we're
the greatest and we can now just enjoy
life the moment you enjoy your life
you're done
gary in in basketball it doesn't mean
that you don't have to enjoy your life
of course gary in basketball they say
your knees go right
in baseball you're just getting older
because you can't run as fast let's just
say football you just can't run or throw
the way you're throwing the ball unless
if your name is brady
but in in your world what goes because
it's not like you're running to make a
move you're sitting there you're making
a move so the career can be longer
what what eventually gets to a point is
it just the fact that you're like 21
years i've been everybody it doesn't
matter to me anymore it doesn't i don't
get the same satisfaction wanting to win
anymore what what goes away in your
world i don't know if you understand the
question i'm asking i do okay i do yes
the two two factors one is as as you
described you know
you're getting not bored but you're
running out of
excitement
uh just bringing back the theme that i
just mentioned at the beginning of our
conversation
i reached a point where i knew i would
not able to make the same difference
yeah it's winning yeah but it's not not
the same drive but also age you know age
counts because it's all about energy
that you can spend and concentration
and concentration means that you know
your brains you know you know
piece of mental power you can you can
mobilize it's there
you're getting older you have families
you have kids you know your other things
and it's
trust me it's impossible you know just
to switch oh i do six hours you know
just and then i
no you cannot forget it it's somewhere
in your some conscience now i'm i'm i
retired from professional chess in 2005.
i play occasionally some events and
people say gary you know how to move the
pieces you know you yeah why don't you
just go back and say guys
how can i do that i have so many things
you know i cannot you know just erase
everything it's not a hard disk
so i cannot you know just do the
sweeping operation uh you know in my in
my brains at any any moment you know i'm
at the board so i will be still you know
having some thoughts you know that that
that will basically jeopardize this this
mental process concentration
it's not it's not there because i'm you
know it's somehow over last 16 years
this is i rebuild my the working
algorithm so i can do things you know
one hour two hours presentations but not
six hours game not even 25 minutes
because it's just it's a different kind
of exercise
big deal so again you just have to
remember what you can do and what you
cannot do
gary uh when you when you're looking at
the game of chess what how do you see
the game like from your lens if you put
your lens on so we can learn from you do
you look at it as war do you look at it
as uh uh purely from a mathematics you
know point of view how are you looking
at the game
uh it's it's a game so it's the i don't
think it's it's mathematics or or or any
other science it's it requires a lot of
preparation so i
um i'm still very passionate about the
game so i love the game i i like
watching i love watching the games like
playing you know online and just doing
exhibitions so it still
takes a considerable part of my life
again i just know my limitations that
i'm no longer professional player i'm
probably the strongest amateur on the
planet
but
when i play chess it's
it was everything so that's again you
play you have to
invest you know all you have into the
game so whether it's you may call it a
war it's a side they may call
psychological warfare because we're
sitting against each other and it's just
it's the if
thanks to the queen's gambit i think a
lot of people recognize the intensity of
the game
so i i was very proud that you know as
an advisor to scott frank so i added so
many details that made it very realistic
and and for those because very often i'm
being asked you know what are the
pictures i'm sure many of you watch this
the series that's this was best harmon
looking at the ceiling with the pic they
said oh it's it's it's hollywood i said
no no that's not hollywood it's a
hollywood production but that's exactly
how many of us you know thought during
the game just you look at the board but
then you can take your eyes away that's
this is the way that you can just
somehow refresh your your
attitude so and just to find some new
new ideas because we don't have to look
at the board just to analyze it so um i
you know i again enjoyed it immensely
and and i can i
it was a never-ending process of
acquiring data analyzing it and coming
up with new ideas fresh ideas yeah i i
ask it for a reason i'll get to my
question a minute here but let me go in
a different direction so in business
world you'll have a business plan we
write a business plan and here's what
we're going to do q1 this month second
quarter third quarter fourth quarter and
then we're going to expand here we're
going to take this cap and i'm going to
hire five employees here we're going to
go to this office anyways you put a
business plan together
and then covet happens and then
somebody in your company leaves and goes
to the competitor they take three
clients away from you things adjust how
much of the game you play
you play because you're initiating and
making can react to you and how much of
it is it you're reacting to your
opponent's moves
um
i think when people talked about charles
darwin i think often they got it wrong
because actually the darwin
theory said that it's not the
strongest piece
species
that survive not the smartest
but the most adaptable to change
that's it so it's about your ability to
adapt and these days it's the most
valuable quality power what guarantees
success
as you said call it happens things can
happen
and it's just it's it's you know and
and that's why you know i always argued
and it's it's my book in a special
chapter how life immediate chess special
chapter called attackers advantage
yes people know that if you are in the
attack you take risk
but there was also benefits because you
are ahead
you you can be ahead of the co just on
this curve sure and see what's happening
there so i think these days
attackers advantage is more valuable
than ever
wow
because because again it's
taking risk is risky yep
not taking risk is much riskier
what split would you put on that 80 20
70 i don't know this is yeah that's that
depends but it's you know it's for so
long
we knew that you know that's the um
the uh the
philosophy of business was to mitigate
risk how to reduce it
and by the way this is once i did an
experiment so um
uh you can use a google engram and you
can look at the books for 100 years
and and find out how certain words have
been used
and uh you know you can check and it's
it's it's always you know shows the the
the uh the change in the public attitude
and and and technology you put the word
computer you put it on the phone so
phone goes up and then a little bit down
and then with mobile phones goes up
against there's only one word that i
found that that didn't behave you know
following the pattern
it's called risk
until mid late 60s it was almost
non-existing
and then it jumped
exponentially
we discovered risk and we wanted to
mitigate this risk
we wanted to handle it we want to
minimize it
forgetting the fact that oh if you
minimize risk you also have to sacrifice
benefits
ah we can print money of course
that's what we've been doing for a long
time
so to compensate
but it's it's it's you know it's insane
just even to think you know how many
great things happened in the past
because people didn't you know pay much
attention to risk
the
every of you has a mobile device
that is 10 000 times more powerful
than all computing power of nasa in 1969
when americans landed in the moon
so
maybe that's that's happened because
they couldn't calculate the risk
because today we would know that the
risk of losing the crew would be 25 to
30 percent
show me the president of the united
mission today
so again is this discovering risk has
consequences
yeah risk risk is a problem but you know
it's the you know we we build systems
you know that's that had to make sure
that you know no risk will find a hole
to to to uh jeopardize our business yeah
it's this by
uh fda regulations you know penicillin
would be banned today the first test
because every person shows allergy some
people say even maybe even tylenol will
not make it through
so what's happened during the pandemics
all of a sudden
rules changed
because the companies that abandoned
research in antibiotics and vaccines for
a simple reason
because 95
90 was not good
it 99.9 you know could lead to a trouble
you know with a army of lawyers you know
going after you if you fail once but now
we needed something we needed a miracle
and and i think that's now we're seeing
this change in this attitude it's more
and more people recognize that you know
you have to incorporate risk yes
it's risky yes you can lose but you have
potential benefits at the end of the day
that's that's about capitalism
you just said
it's the
you know
it's uh winston churchill said that uh
the inherit wise of capitalism is an
equal
distribution of the blessing of
blessings
but the
inherent
virtue of socialism is equal sharing of
miseries
so
yeah we you know we have to take out we
have to take our chances yes and and i
think again this is we have something
that was not available in 1969 or in the
70s or the 80s we have these very
powerful devices
you know just how do we use them you
know do we use them wisely do we use
them effectively
i don't think so
so just you know find a way to utilize
this enormous power that have been
created in the free world
and again which we showed with vaccines
it took 10 months to come up with
vaccines by the way created in the free
world
for those who are arguing about the two
different systems i always tell we had
an experiment
china gave us virus america gave us
vaccine
i like the fact that you're not uh very
controversial and you you play the
safety
yeah i
there is a room you would be safer to
talk about that stuff more it would prob
there's probably that room doesn't exist
this is the safest room for you to talk
about what you just talked about uh but
let's go back a little bit more deeper
into that you know
i was gonna do q and a's but i'm going
to take some of their time and i'm going
to ask you the questions
so
this young lady over here talked about
how last night she had meetings with a
couple other people
and they were talking about what it was
like to be in russia what it was like to
be an immigrant why they love america so
much you know what makes this thing so
special you talked about baku you talked
about your first experience when you
went to a capitalistic country and
you're like i've never seen this before
because my brain was you know controlled
in a certain way i was born and raised
in iran i lived there ten years
in iran it's married
death upon america this is the worst
country in the world
why is that there's a competition why
why why is it why is it why is it that
so many
so many people who have lived in a
communistic socialistic regime
are doing whatever they can to come to
capitalistic what makes it sexy what is
such a big turn off with communism and
socialism to you look
it's about freedom
i agree
it's about that you it's look there's no
guarantee of success but you have a
chance can i can i stop you right there
here's the angle i want you to take
present to us what it was like to live
in a communistic regime what was that
like because again they p most people
don't know that life they don't know
that world and then give thanks god you
don't know yeah if you don't mind
presenting i don't think i can tell you
in a few minutes
but you you know it's
i think the problem with americans you
take things for granted
you
you keep forgetting the wise wars of
ronald reagan you know from just i think
1967 his inaugural speech when he became
governor of california that freedom is a
fragile thing
and it's never more than one generation
away from extinction
that's why i think it's so important to
hear people like me
but maybe i'm just i'm the wrong person
because i was successful
but there's so many people coming to
america they look at america the way we
looked you know from the other side of
our curtain
for us it was a proverbial
shining city on a hill yeah we knew
america had problems
again there's no perfection in this
world
but you compare this country to any
other place on the planet
you will not find a place that offers
more opportunities
for people you know just of all races
genders you know with this is
and that's why people like me are just
getting so um
concerned
when
self-criticism turns into
self-regulation
because every time you know we hear you
know this is these the noises in this
country that are aimed at the very
foundation of this great nation
that's what helps dictators in russia in
china and iran because ah look at
america
america is bad america is built on evil
nonsense
this country was built on on great
expectations of people that wanted to
build a
want to create
a world to
you know for free people just
full of opportunities
and
while there's always room for
improvement
but you need a good foundation you need
a good basis for that and people like me
would know that
and you know for those who say oh
america
out you know um
overplayed his hand her hand so america
you know went everywhere so this is oh
it's if america should not be a
world policeman
okay fine
you know what happens when policeman is
on a beat look at kabul
so it's the
it's a go it's globalization means that
you have a responsibility and and
america is still a leader
people look at america
as as a country that still can you know
can lead the world free world
unfortunately
they don't have the same america i used
to have when i was a kid living in the
soviet union and we're missing that by
the way you're also missing that because
it's the ignoring the freedom of others
you know basically you know hits you at
home as well
so i'm gonna i i can take my stance so
this is i i know that a lot of people
you know may feel
uncomfortable with what i'm saying but i
speak on behalf of millions and millions
and millions of people from iran
afghanistan russia other places who look
at america and they
they confused they're scared they just
don't understand
how come that this great power now is on
retreat is on the run it's just you know
it's it's it looked inward and it's
destroying the foundation that helped to
build the greatest nation on yours
absolutely
why why didn't you
you know you you had political
aspirations you know i don't you did
you have i never had it no no in oh wait
you said you wanted to run look at all
this running in putin's russia was like
sending a message because you i knew
that i would never be on the ballot
this is just again it's and by the way
it was in 2007
that's what i called
vegetarian time in russia because for
protesting in the streets you can end up
in jail as myself for five or ten days
being beaten abused but today
if you show up on the street it will be
five to ten years
so um
look i marched and we did it peacefully
yeah i can proudly say that unlike in
many other countries including this one
during our protests from 2005 to 2011
we did not have a single broken window
i'm not even talking about burn cars the
only violence on the streets of russia
was caused by putin's riot police and
and security officers
people who marched with me
they eat in exile like myself
in jail like alexis divali or killed
like boris themself
that's that's a sad reality of russia
and all we have there is a window
window you know built by a kgb officer
to sell to the western leaders that
would like to
buy this this this fake story
unfortunately many of them
and by the way one thing that putin did
i have to say that it's
give him credit he proved
that
the west also could be corrupt
it's it's
i never thought that you know i would
see
widespread corruption in the free world
the way putin exposed it
because he had access to more money than
any other individual in the history of
humanity i think directly or indirectly
he controls something like one trillion
dollars
one trillion dollars through russian
budget funds oligarchs fortunes and he
can move money here and there
and it's proved irresistible
and um and that's a pro that's again
that tells you that our problem is also
your problem
because it it's it's alive the uh the
institutions that guaranteed uh your
freedom
and your prosperity why why wouldn't you
have political aspirations though i mean
if you if you think in in your
vocal and the way you're giving your
points truth is cutting through lies and
controversy and you're doing it in a way
somebody says this makes sense why
wouldn't you use that ability to go do
something good
look again i i
i always thought that i was i wasn't in
the field of
human rights and democracy i'm
i don't have you know they
probably just i'm i'm not built just you
to to to
to run the campaign and just it's the
i'm happy to support the right people
i'm yeah i'm i'm
i want to inspire people i just you know
i just that's a part
but
i don't know i just did i never i never
thought of myself just running for an
office uh
doing it seriously because there's so
many other things i can do yeah yeah
maybe it's wrong i don't know no but
it's not but i'm i'm i'm not even i i
live here on the green cards so as the
it's uh um
and um i
i cannot run from office here so
although
anyway but i'm very happy to inspire
those who are willing to take their
chances and i'm you know i'm ready to
throw my we don't know each other wait
this is the first time we're meeting yes
uh yeah if you don't count this zoom
assume that we are but this is the first
time you're in our physical meeting
you know uh uh
almost everybody that
eventually like the people i'm concerned
about that run are the people that from
they were six years old they wanted to
be a president one day that's the guy
that wants power i'm concerned about
that but sometimes
you know there there are
eras where a person has the capability
to go face off some of the bigger tough
guys and the bullies and you don't seem
to be afraid and the way you process
issues and present your
message to people it inspires others so
i don't know i i think you ought to
consider doing something with that
ability how many guys would agree with
that
i think it's a
i i think the world would benefit from
it if you got a little more involved but
anyways i don't want to uh instigate i
have a tendency of doing that i want to
open it up for ceos i want these guys to
ask some questions here wow
let's anybody from russia that has a
question any ceos from russia that has
the questions okay joanna's really got a
question here school right here she's
from mexico i think right now where do
you live right now
i live in mexico but i'm originally from
romania so i was born and raised in
communism you're actually one of our
heroes so uh thanks for coming my
question is about the 1997 deep blue
after 19 moves you resigned but the
interesting part is you actually change
your style it was like a wait and see
approach why did you change your style
and do you think that affected your
designation uh look uh thank you for
bringing this very memorable moment
[Laughter]
uh
look it's i lost the game before i move
the pieces it's just because it was very
tough match it was you know even after
five games i was very close and winning
in game five and by the way if you look
at the game five from today's
perspectives using the chess engines
they'll tell you that all the
compliments were heard in 1997 from
people say oh kasparov played great game
deep blue defended
the laughing loud so that says this
machines will tell you that the blue uh
uh made mistakes i made mistakes and i
missed the win and i could feel it that
i missed the win and also we had a lot
of arguments with ibm so again what
under the bridge so i already made my
piece with them but i had a lot of
arguments with them during the match and
i was human
uh one of the mistakes actually of many
you know that's this that we had the um
the rules that we played two games then
rest day two games two rest days and two
games i mean i had to insist on one
break just i needed this you know after
game five i needed one day just two two
two to get my you know just myself back
to the
that's the so i'm human i proved that i
was human so and that was a purely human
disaster so it's the which again was
another demonstration that it's it's all
about making fewer mistakes
awesome
right back there back there yes
hi gary uh
actually i followed you during the uh
and i'm also from romania so i grew up
in a community's country
uh so i think we attract a lot of
communists that yes
but
my question my question i have for you
um
i i also play competitive chess and i
know the mental toughness of the game
my question to you is is there something
that you did
the day before the week of to prepare
you mentally which can help us as
business owners as we're going into a
meeting or some kind of a challenging uh
situation that
maybe you can talk about like what did
you do to prepare for a big event like
that
you totally you're testing my memory
i played competitive chess a long time
ago yeah
uh um
look um
i wish we could i'm looking at the clock
now i wouldn't worry about it we could
have this question you know at the
beginning of the conversation
because it um
it's actually it's much bigger issue for
me than just preparing for one game
because there's something that i always
thought was wrong is to
ask for tips
and let me explain why because we're all
different
yeah we
we different
in
for many many reasons so and and the way
we make decisions
our decision-making formula is as unique
as our dna or our fingerprints
so it's
having one universe advice for everybody
could be wrong
because if you got for bed forbid get
sick so you don't have the same medicine
as i do so you need your tests so same
is here is as you know the
the beginning of the process of
improving your
decision-making process of getting sort
of a more acquainted with who you are is
just analyzing and recognizing that i'm
more aggressive i'm more conservative
and also recognizing that this is your
nature you know it's
it's it's a very unique process
and i'm i don't know about you i'm just
you know
i'm
an extrovert i'm just a very dynamic so
i knew what worked for me
might be counterproductive for you so
it's very important to know who you are
and how you build your bose
preparation but also the game
because the strategy should reflect
your ability to master it at every point
and what i know about
chess and about probably any other walk
of life is that no matter how much
preparation
we did before no matter how much time we
spend analyzing our performance
opponent's performance the key is you
know to make sure that the at the climax
where we have little time left to make a
decision
and this decision could be really you
know faithful so it could actually it
could
decide the outcome of the game
we have to be comfortable
so that's why you know it's just it's um
the the way to design your preparation
and the game
same goes for business or for politics
is to make sure you're comfortable
that it works for you
and it's always unique
and um and again it's just it's it's
it's it's also includes you know your
knowledge of the opponents
because you want to make sure that you
face the opposition
on the field that that that benefits you
so that that that puts puts emphasis on
your advantages and also um you know
exposes opponents weaknesses
and just it's the um
just let me give you this look like the
visual example
it's it's you have two armies
um
uh in the medieval battlefield
so both you know
of equal strengths
both you know um uh of armies um have
talented generals in charge
but one army has
powerful cavalry
another has skillful archers as the key
components
the outcome of the battle most likely
will be decided by the terrain
landscape in the valley the cavalry will
run them down in this in the hills
the the archers will put cavalry down so
again it's all about creating conditions
where your strengths
will be a key factor and opponents
strengths will be
downplayed
yeah okay
so how often do you see somebody who's
very analytical yet charismatic and
inspirational you don't meet too many
people like that by the way and he's a
trifecta yes go for it
i'm
emigrated from russia i can hear it
my name is sergey plonikov i have two
questions you have two foundations one
is promoting chess with children
and if i correctly second foundation
it's your human rights uh help
so if you can explain what you do in
this field and second what is your
biggest challenge right now in your life
um
so uh kasparov just foundation i
mentioned i founded it here in 2002
we'll be celebrating 20th anniversary
next year
uh that has branches around the world so
that's the that's quite a big
uh charitable organization that
does two things one is working with kids
promoting blueprint curriculum but also
working with rising stars mostly in
america but now we extended our services
to to europe and also the
russian-speaking world um now uh
human rights foundation i i'm a chairman
for nearly 10 years but i am followed
the um the footsteps of one of my heroes
vassal havel the
former president of czechoslovakia the
great human rights activist who's the
president of the country
and um and i
i am ago i'm proud to be
affiliate was the organization that
built
the largest dissident event in the world
called ozil freedom forum
uh so by the way we it's it's called all
the freedom forum but it's it's a global
event and one of them might will take
place in miami in the beginning of
october so and we have all leading
dissidents and it's all about stories
it's not about numbers data it's it's
about real stories
so for instance uh
on on this event in in in miami uh four
weeks from now one of the speeches you
know will be delivered by alex navalny's
daughter that was message from from
so that's the we have leopold lopez from
venezuela so one of these opposition
leaders there so and many people go just
ranging from north korea to to uh to
cuba
so now about greatest challenges
some people say staying alive
we do one more who really really really
has a good question really is it
positive this is tomorrow
from azerbaijan i don't know what she's
going to ask
okay
what's okay tell me what your question's
about just give me the topic one word
brain what's yours about tomorrow
give me one word
okay no you can't i'm not that's not
telling me what's your question yes
how about yourself
passion somebody
wow all right let's go to tomorrow
tomorrow tell us what your question is
no because this one could get
interesting here we go
hi um first of all please don't hate me
too much for asking another question um
when i'm when something matters to me i
go all in and i will never apologize for
that
[Applause]
so
a couple of i think was yesterday the
day before that patrick asked us
what is your future truth
my page was blank
because my future truth is dangerous
my future truth has consequences
and my future truth is not just getting
cancelled on social media it's getting
in actual trouble and having my family
getting in trouble
but
hearing you speak not now i want to say
my future truth is that i will end
communism in the former ussr countries
and i will start with russia i'll be
honored if you support me in my future
political campaigns
it's a very ambitious goal so i
it's
look um
um
being being an optimist i also you know
have to to
inject the dose of realism and i
and i understand that you know fighting
putin's dictatorship may not bring
benefits tomorrow
maybe not even day after tomorrow i i
live outside of russia for eight years i
don't expect to come
back tomorrow um
so a lot of people ask me so can i go
back to russia i say yes it will be a
one-way ticket
i always buy a round trip
and um
and i am
i think that is just you know ending
it's not even a communism so in russia
this is it's it's a new form of
dictatorship which is even much worse
and more dangerous
because communism
was an ideology and you could see the
shortcomings of this of the ideology
people in the west they could say it's
propaganda it's this is that's the um
it's you know it's some
it has you know its own
domestic difficulties and it couldn't
compete
putin actually came up with something
far more sophisticated
because the way they
distort the picture
the way they distort the truth is
basically saying truths cannot be known
yeah with that everybody is bad we
corrupt everybody is corrupt good thing
i work in tech and i'm very data driven
when it comes to that truth does exist
truth yeah we know that truth does exist
but there's only one way to tell the
truth and there are millions of ways
thanks to social media to to lie
truth is lonely
and and we just you know we have to find
ways to defend it and they actually
recognize that it's they don't have to
sell an ideology
yeah i always call putin merchant of
doubt
yeah it's easy you know it's easy to
spread doubts especially with the money
that he has and with so many willing
souls in the free world to buy it
so
that's why this is not a russian problem
this is not a problem of former soviet
republics foreign in the former soviet
union this is everybody's problem
because it's a globalized world and i
again i hope that we can fight together
because this fight you know does not
have borders does not have limitations
this is a fight for our future for
future our kids
and uh
i know i know it's from the bottom of my
heart i know from my experience there is
no compromise
you we cannot
we cannot end the war that was declared
on us
and this is we are in the midst of this
war
you can pretend that oh we just you know
we ended the war in afghanistan no we
have not entered the war we'll run
and there's a big difference because
those who won there
they are still at war with us
so this is we we should look at this
world you know with open eyes and be
optimistic but also recognizing the
danger
because the moment we
look the other side it hits us as it
happened 20 years ago in this country
the sad celebration okay amen
celebrations
anniversary that we would we would
uh remember a week from now
so i uh um
i am i'm happy to to to to end this
conversation on such a high note because
this is for me it's um
yeah
it's if it happens it will bring me a
chance to go back to
to my country
and just to to visit my mother's grave
which unfortunately is many thousand
miles away and i couldn't stand there
give it up gary kasparov if you didn't
know gary kasparov is our mini i want to
make sure you knew about this gary's
armenian anyways i really enjoyed this
interview one of my favorite interviews
uh all year long i did a lot of
different topics about communism russia
putin his view on politics he should be
talking more about politics if you
enjoyed this interview give it a thumbs
up and comment below on what you took
away and i have another video i think
you'll like as well it's a video there's
a talk i gave in long beach a few years
ago titled think like a grand master if
you've never seen that click over here
to watch it take care everybody bye
[Music]